everybody needs to buckle up because
things are about to get absolutely
insane
as donald trump is set to nominate one
of
a few dystopian handmaid's tale
type ideologues cultists literal
cultists
to the supreme court to replace ruth
bader ginsburg
donald trump has said he will be making
the announcement saturday
5 p.m eastern from the white house
one of the people donald trump is
reportedly considering
who is again reports are that she is the
front runner
is judge amy coney barrett
who is against roe v wade against
abortion
connected to the right-wing federalist
society
part of a pseudo-religious cult
and has a long list of absolutely
disturbing beliefs which we are going to
discuss
now why is amy coney barrett a known
entity
she's a known entity because back in
2017
under trump she was confirmed to the
seventh circuit court of appeals
and so we learned a lot about her in
2017 to start with
she is a strict constructionist who
has criticized roe v wade many times
and said that the court is likely to
chip away
at abortion protections on the friday
show i'll talk more about
what that could actually look like
barrett and her husband are
members of a group called people of
praise
this is a cult i got emails from viewers
whose families were previously involved
with people of praise it is a
pseudo-religious pseudo church cult it's
not exactly a church
it's a christian para-church
organization and it is reminiscent of
gilead
in margaret atwood's handmaid's tale if
you read about people of praise you will
see that for example the highest office
a woman can hold
in a people of praise community is now
called woman leader
it used to be called handmade i i'm not
exaggerating
this is literally trump going in the
direct
direction of margaret atwood's gilead
i'm not making it up
as i mentioned barrett used to be a
member of the federalist society that's
the group
that actually was bankrolling the
nomination of brett
kavanaugh to the court amy coney barrett
is eager to get rid of obamacare
barrett reportedly spoke to students
well no she did speak to students at
notre dame
uh and reportedly said that a legal
career
is merely a means to an end and that the
end
wait for it is building the kingdom
of god a religious cultist who believes
legal careers are meant to serve
god is potentially going to be nominated
to the supreme court
to replace ruth bader ginsburg
that is what we are up against here 77
000 votes in three states got us here
today
now barrett is only a few of what are
considered to be the front runners
so we could go into barrett's court
decisions which are
disturbing but she may not actually be
the nominee so we'll wait on that we'll
wait and see who actually is selected on
saturday the time will come for that
so we are slowly but surely moving more
and more towards a status quo
that resembles that of dystopian fiction
including that described by margaret
atwood
in uh handmaid's tale and the sequel the
testaments which i also
recommend i read it a couple months ago
and this is where we are we have an
election
in under six weeks to go from ruth bader
ginsburg to this lunacy is beyond
devastating gilead is a sort of
republican religious right-winger wet
dream
and it is what donald trump is creating
a sort of male-dominated conservative
society suppression of minority rights
prevalence of certain people seen more
as though they are less than human and
more like property
than others not literal slavery of
course the suppression of women's rights
it's all happening margaret atwood
created the story
to serve as a warning and the republican
party
under donald trump is using it almost
like a blueprint
republicans are trying to create that
religious body within government within
the supreme court giving them
veto power over culture and society it's
not
just this is this is no longer like left
versus right
it's far deeper than that it's
ideological it's dystopian it's a
nightmare
and we can't control everything as i
said
but we can still control whether we all
get out and vote
45 of eligible adults didn't
vote in 2016. non-voters
won so to speak or if non-voting was a
candidate
non-voting would have won in something
like
85 or 90 percent of the states in 2016.
let's not forget that we we have agency
here
we can take action but it looks like
it's going to get very very ugly very
very quickly
let me know your thoughts about the
direction of all of this i'm on twitter
at d pacman one of our sponsors today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you up to 30 percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
slash watch if you're looking for an
awesome way to
update your look the perfect way to do
it is with an
elegant high quality wrist watch when
there's a company like vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company that's made it
possible to own
an excellent watch without breaking the
bank all of their watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video